>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mark Horowitz: Hi,
I'm Mark Horowitz.
I'm a Music Specialist in the Music
Division at The Library of Congress
and I'm currently the Archivist for
the Leonard Bernstein Collection,
but with me is, among other
things, the previous Archivist
for the Bernstein Collection,
Charlie Harmon,
and thank you for coming.
>> Charlie Harmon:
You're very welcome.
>> Mark Horowitz: And I just wanted
to start with some information
about you, what was your background,
your educational experience before
you became involved in all of this?
>> Charlie Harmon:
Yeah, I have a degree
in Music Composition
from Carnegie Mellon.
I left, I graduated in 1973.
I had gone to Carnegie
Mellon in architecture,
really couldn't get my brain around
the profession of architecture,
it just it's really hard.
Music was a lot easier.
And the important thing in the 60s
was to, the late 60s was to stay
in school and not be drafted.
So I dropped into the Music
Department, which was one floor
down at Carnegie Mellon
at that point.
So when I, as a grownup
I was a computer operator
for a little company in Boston.
And a friend, one of my
roommates from Carnegie Mellon,
was living in New York doing
his postdoctoral research
at the Rockefeller University, and
he said you need to move to New York
because the opportunities are here.
And I did and I worked at a
company called Tams-Witmark,
which licenses Broadway material.
I liked it very much.
It paid very well.
And I met Dale Kugel, who
became a mentor to me.
It was the first time I'd thought
of someone as a real mentor.
And he wanted to hire me to
be his copyist assistant,
assistant librarian, and
that wasn't in the cards.
So I was looking at the
classified section every Sunday
in the New York Times, back when
it was 100 pages every week.
It was pretty impressive.
And there was always something
under music in the New York Times,
even though obviously to
get into the music business
in New York you had
to know somebody.
It was all about who knew
talent that was in the city.
But there was this one
ad that said, musician,
world class needs assistant,
must be free to travel,
familiar with European
languages, super organized --
it didn't say super, but it had
to be very well organized --
and be able to read
music, and that was it.
And then a box so you
could send your resume.
And I thought, huh.
I've lived overseas when
my father was in the Army.
We lived in Germany and Italy.
I could still read
German and Italian,
but at that point I had let it lapse
and I couldn't really
have a conversation.
I could certainly read music.
I was very organized.
I mean everything, I've always
when I receive letters I file them
in boxes, I mean it's just, but
I do, I just organize stuff.
All my books and music
were always alphabetized.
So I sent off my resume,
which was about this long.
And I got a call and it was from
Mimsy Gill, who was secretary
to someone named Harry Kraut.
Not a clue who the world
class musician was.
And they asked me to
come in for an interview,
and the interview went
on for three hours.
>> Mark Horowitz: Just with Harry?
>> Charlie Harmon: Just with Harry.
First thing he said was,
it's Leonard Bernstein.
And I said, oh.
That's, let me think,
Leonard Bernstein.
I'd never seen Bernstein conduct
except on young people's concerts.
I hadn't read any of his books.
I had two recordings that I
liked, the Bartok Concerto
for Orchestra and, oh,
Robert Schumann Symphony No.
3. And what I remembered, I remember
sitting there talking to Harry
and thinking of that
Robert Schumann recording
and the cover had the Cathedral
of Cologne and a portrait
of Leonard Bernstein and
they were the same size.
And I remember just sitting
there thinking, yes, okay,
Leonard Bernstein has an ego as big
as the Cathedral of
Cologne [laughter].
Harry didn't tell me much more
than that, and so I prodded him
and I said, this was in October of
1981, and I said what's the schedule
in 1982, you know,
what's he doing in 1982?
And Harry talked for 45 minutes
without pause, without any notes,
a week-by-week summary of what
the maestro was doing in 1982.
And at the end of 45
minutes I was stunned.
I mean he began by -- I mean
he would mention the orchestras
and where we would be and if an
orchestra was being taken on tour.
And at that point I had
crossed the Atlantic six times
in my life and I was 31 years old.
And in the first six months
there were about eight crossings
of the Atlantic, and I
thought this is just insane,
this is an insane schedule.
So after the 45 minutes I said,
I think you need a very high
energy person for this job
and I've never been high energy.
And I said, I think you need
someone about half my age.
And Harry let me talk
about myself for awhile.
And one of the things I had -- I
was doing, I shared an apartment
in Brooklyn Heights and I
and my neighbors had decided
to have a New Year's Eve party.
We just decided, we were happy
in New York and we were going
to invite all our friends.
We I think invited 250 people
and they all showed up.
And we decided to cater
it ourselves.
And so what I did was I made all the
cookies and I made 80 dozen cookies.
And Harry said, oh, yeah,
a party for 200 people,
I know exactly the
caterer I would call.
And I said, well, we don't
have that kind of budget,
so I made 80 dozen cookies.
And Harry was completely
taken aback.
He'd never met anybody who
would just nonchalantly turn
out 80 dozen cookies
and throw a party.
I mean it was ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Still
have them ...
>> Charlie Harmon:
It's not hard to do
because once you start
baking it's just a, you know,
you just have to have the
space to let them cool
and the tins to put them in.
He was wildly impressed.
He told me this later after I
was hired, he said the two things
that really impressed him was the 80
dozen cookies and that at the bottom
of my resume I had listed the
three high schools that I went to
and the first one was in
Naples, Italy run by the US Navy
and he had never met anyone who
went to high school in Naples,
and he thought this
is exactly the person.
>> Mark Horowitz: Do you have any
idea how many people they actually
interviewed for the job?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, he told
me, this was years later he told me
that they usually got 200 responses
and they would throw out 190 of them
because they were on the ad in
the Times and the Village Voice.
And you can imagine the
responses they got from the ad
in the Village Voice, especially
since it didn't say who it was,
it just said world class musician.
Well, you know, what,
Bob Dillon, who is it?
And he said they just, they
knew instantly which ones,
which applications to throw out.
But he liked what I had listed,
you know, the green composition,
the languages, the ability
to travel and the --
well, he didn't know
how organized I was.
So I, when I left the
interview I said,
I don't think I can
do this, and I left.
And I had some other
interviews that fall.
I can't remember now what they were.
And I think around Thanksgiving I
called, it was the Amberson office
at that point, and I
called the office and talked
to Mimsy Gill, Harry's secretary.
And said, look, just
keep my name in the mix,
I'm sure you're still
having interviews.
Well, they weren't.
And just let me know, you know,
if something falls into place.
So the first working day after
New Year's in 1982 Harry called me
at Tams and said, you can have
it, we're going to hire you,
you have to fly to Bloomington,
Indiana this Friday --
this was a Tuesday -- and you'll
meet Lenny in Bloomington.
And I said, I can't
talk on the phone,
because personal calls were
not allowed at Tams-Witmark.
I said, I'll come to your office
this afternoon, this evening.
When I walked into the Amberson
offices Harry was on the phone
with the Student Union
in Bloomington making my
accommodation reservation.
And I said, well, if you really
think I can do it, okay, I'll do it.
We hadn't talked about a
salary or anything like that.
>> Mark Horowitz: And it didn't need
Lenny's approval, the hiring of you?
>> Charlie Harmon:
Lenny, Lenny trusted Harry
with a lot of those details.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was Jack
Gottlieb the person before you
or was there somebody else ...
>> Charlie Harmon: No, Daryl
Bornstein came before me,
and I don't know why he -- I can't
remember how long he stuck with it,
but I think it was
less than two years.
And there was an interim assistant,
Richard Nelson, wonderful actor.
He's out in LA.
And I don't remember how
he came into the picture,
but he was doing some
travel with Bernstein
and I think maybe helping
out Daryl for awhile.
Before Daryl there was
a string of assistants.
Lenny told me at one point, well,
one of them lasted
for only four days.
He'd show up, you know,
someone would show up,
see how overwhelming the
position was and then just leave.
>> Mark Horowitz: What
was your title?
>> Charlie Harmon: Assistant,
Assistant to Leonard Bernstein.
But I never had a business
card or anything like that.
There wasn't anything like that.
>> Mark Horowitz: And in addition
to your salary they covered all
your travel costs and hotels?
>> Charlie Harmon: Right,
and when I talked to Harry
about salary I had never
bartered for a salary in my life,
Harry offered -- he asked me how
much I was being paid at Tams
and I told him, I was
way too honest.
And he offered about,
it was about 20% more.
And I didn't know what to
do, so there was a pause
and Harry assumed that I agreed.
[laughter] And it really
should have been
about three times what
he offered me.
It wasn't really enough
to live on in New York.
I mean I was really scrambling.
And New York was cheap in
1981, I mean relatively cheap.
But I mean for a dollar you
could get a newspaper and get
on the subway, it was ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Were you
able to negotiate raises?
>> Charlie Harmon: No,
and that was something --
I just didn't have it in
me, and there were times
when over the four years
of being the Assistant
that I would ask Harry, how do I --
I really need to be paid more
for working 80 hours a week.
And he said, it'll just put
you in a higher tax bracket.
[laughter] And I just, I ...
>> Mark Horowitz: So you worked
for four years in this position?
>> Charlie Harmon: So I flew out
to Indiana that Friday with Harry.
Harry said he'd tell me everything
I needed to know on the flight.
He promptly fell asleep.
No conversation at
all on the flight,
and I still hadn't met Bernstein.
And it wasn't until
the next day in Indiana
that Bernstein arrived
and I met him.
And I thought this derelict, this
decrepit geriatric who was drunk,
this -- he hadn't slept,
he hadn't shaved that day.
He obviously had not showered.
And I thought he was nuts, I
thought he was completely nuts.
He was very lively, but when --
after this condo outside of
Bloomington, after he arrived
with this barrage of
university people behind him,
and Richard Nelson and
Harry and Stephen Zinzer,
Stephen Wadsworth Zinzer, who
was collaborating on what turned
into A Quiet Place, and Ann Dedman,
who was the chef and also sort
of a traveling household manager.
So all these people arrived,
and I mean I wasn't
even introduced to him.
Harry said my name, and
Bernstein didn't even --
he couldn't really focus, he
was just manic at that moment.
So I took, he had this huge parka,
I took the parka off his
shoulders and hung it up.
And I asked him if
he wanted a drink?
And he said, well,
what are you drinking?
And I had poured about a
tablespoon of gin into a glass
because I thought I might need it,
my nerves were a little
up at that point.
And he grabbed the glass
out of my hand and drank it.
And I said, that's my drink.
And he said, you don't
talk that way to the rabbi.
And I didn't know what to do, I
mean I didn't think he was a rabbi
and I thought he was really
angry, I thought he was, you know,
I wasn't so fine and
maybe I was fired already.
And I just kind of
stood around mopey.
[laughter] He was talking to
everybody else individually,
all these people that
he obviously knew.
And after about a half hour he said,
well, I want to see the bedroom.
Because the piano, there was an
upstairs with a huge master suite,
there was a desk in there
and there was a piano.
It overlooked, there was a wall of
windows that overlooked Lake Monroe.
It was frozen, of course,
in January.
It was a nice room, but that's
basically where he was going
to sleep and work for six weeks.
And my concern was is
this a workable space,
can you write an opera here?
And instead he wanted to
see how I had unpacked.
I mean the luggage came from New
York and I unpacked underwear
for someone I'd never met and ...
>> Mark Horowitz: So as Assistant
it wasn't just musical things,
it was everything.
>> Charlie Harmon: It was
picking up the laundry,
it was answering the phone.
But Harry did say that I was
hired because there is a deadline
for this opera, a three-part
commission from Houston Grand Opera,
La Scala in the Kennedy Center, and
the premiere was June 17th, 1983,
so the opera had to be done on time.
And I said, well, fine, June -- at
this interview in October of '81,
I said June of '83,
that's plenty of time.
Well, I didn't know what was
going to get in the way ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Sort of corral
Bernstein and say you need
to work now or try and ...
>> Charlie Harmon: No, he, you
know, he also was super organized
and he understood what --
at that point in his life certainly
understood how a collaboration
would work.
I think Steve Wadsworth had to
corral Bernstein quite a bit,
especially once they
got some momentum going,
Lenny would just find other things
to do, you know, the social calendar
for instance, that would
just take over in New York.
And Stephen would call
and say, well,
I really need to see him three
times this week and I need two hours
on this day and I need
two hours on this day.
And that was part of my job,
to make sure that those
meetings actually happened.
And that they wouldn't
be interrupted, you know,
if Adolph Green called in the
middle of one of those sessions
that the two collaborators were
having I would just take a message
or I'd talk to Adolph for
an hour, that was okay.
>> Mark Horowitz: In
the four years you were
with Lenny what were the
major projects that happened?
A Quiet Place.
What other works did he work on?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, A
Quiet Place was really it.
He -- there wasn't that much music.
I think he was a little disappointed
how he didn't have the time
in those years to collaborate more.
He did write Arias and Barcarolles,
but that was completely on his own,
and some little pieces, but other
than A Quiet Place
there was nothing major.
>> Mark Horowitz: So he
was mostly conducting?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yes, it
was a lot of conducting.
He finished the Brahms Cycle
with the Vienna Philharmonic
and a Schumann Cycle, and then
started a new Moller Cycle
for Deutsche Grammophon,
which didn't get completed,
the 8th never go recorded.
And, oh, he did an All
American album in 1982
and he did an English album.
It was an enormous
amount of recording,
and that actually took
a lot of attention.
I mean when he looked at the Elgar
enigma variations in the spring
of 1982, I remember looking through
his score and thinking, well,
you know, there's nothing more
he needs to mark in this piece.
And then he looked at it as though
he'd never looked at it before
and changed all kinds of
things, not so much change
but not changing dynamics for
instance but adding articulation
so that everything would be there
in the parts and he wouldn't have
to explain so much from the podium.
Of course, when you're conducting
an English orchestra in a piece
by Elgar there's already a tradition
that that orchestra brings to it,
but he really put his
own stamp on it.
>> Mark Horowitz: So somebody would
actually go to the musicians' parts
and mark them up based on his
annotations on the full score?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yes,
I ended up doing that.
>> Mark Horowitz: Is
that typical, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: That's --
yes, absolutely, that's what
orchestra librarians do constantly
for -- and a great thing
about the job for me was
that wherever we would go usually
there wasn't enough advanced time
to go to Larry Taro [Assumed
Spelling] at the Philharmonic
and say, here are all
these markings,
transfer them into the parts.
But since we were traveling with
Bernstein's own set of materials,
it was the first time I'd met a
conductor who had his own library,
basically his performance library
came from the New York Philharmonic.
When he left the Philharmonic --
what year was that, '72 I think --
Carlos Moseley [Assumed
Spelling] hadn't really promised,
but somehow said to Bernstein,
well, you can take anything
from the library that you
conducted at the Philharmonic.
And so Bernstein took everything, I
mean all the Beethoven symphonies,
all the Mozart and Haydn,
Stravinsky, everything,
and he just took everything.
>> Mark Horowitz: The
already marked up scores?
>> Charlie Harmon:
Right, scores and parts.
>> Mark Horowitz: Were
they horrified, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, it was a
big loss, but things got replaced.
But there were some things he
should not have taken, but he did.
Toscanini's set of parts
for the Leonore No.
3 Overture of Beethoven, in which
Toscanini changed the orchestration
on the last page of the score,
added brass, just re-voiced chords
and things like that in red pencil.
I mean it's Toscanini's marking
in that score and so they're
in the parts, and that became
Bernstein's set of materials.
All that stuff, you know, it
was all stamped on the front,
Property of the New York
Philharmonic Symphony Association,
or whatever they used
to call themselves.
All that stuff went back to
the Philharmonic archive,
when I became Bernstein's archivist
and catalogued everything that was,
well, existed at that point.
Barbara Haws [Assumed
Spelling] had been --
had created an archive for the New
York Philharmonic and she said,
we think we would like
this stuff returned.
[laughter]
>> Mark Horowitz: Did he do the
Norton lectures while you were
with him, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: No, that was
'72, I think, so it was 10 years ...
>> Mark Horowitz: So there were no
major lecture series, talking's,
anything like that during
the time you were with him?
>> Charlie Harmon:
There really wasn't,
it was an enormous
amount of conducting.
And then that first year we
were on the road from, well,
from Bloomington all the way
through the end of September,
there was really no pause.
Sometimes we would be in Los
Angeles, we were in Los Angeles
for about a month that summer,
but there was something
every single day.
And then after September
he had nine empty months
in which he was supposed
to write the opera.
So he started it in Bloomington.
They got the first act
basically done, not orchestrated,
he wrote in a short
score so it was somewhere
between four and six
staves of music.
And one of the first
things he asked me to do,
I was picking up his laundry in that
room with the piano and the desk
and the bed, he said, don't you
have a degree in composition,
why are you picking up my laundry?
And I said, well, you know, the
laundry has to be picked up.
And he said, well, here, see
what you can do with this,
I need a piano reduction.
And he handed me the scene that
he had finished the night before.
And one of the things that the
Indiana University Jacobs School
of Music, I have to
remember to say that,
offered to do was a readthrough
of each scene as it was completed.
And Stephen Wadsworth
corralled a bunch of singers,
some really marvelous singers, and
some pianists and it got taped,
audiotape, scene by scene, but
they needed something to play from.
And no one, they were not going
to be able to play from, you know,
a Leonard Bernstein
manuscript in short score.
So I started making
a piano reduction,
and it's something I've
always enjoyed doing.
In fact, I used to do
it as an undergraduate,
I would do it just for
fun just for myself.
It was a great way to
learn to read a score
and to see what was important
and it also improved my
music copying skills.
And I did the entire first act.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was he impressed?
>> Charlie Harmon:
No, he said you need
to be more forceful on the page.
[laughter] I said, I'm
just trying to be accurate.
And he said, no, there's more
to it than just being accurate.
And then he would change things.
It was really interesting
because, you know, I'd present him
with a piano reduction, everything
lined up, all the lyrics, you know,
just as clear as could be, always
giving enough horizontal space
for all the lyrics and the vocal
lines always in the same order and,
you know, all that
stuff is important.
And then if he made a
change, and he was --
he really looked at
every single note
that I had copied in
my piano reduction.
He liked that I made
it playable, but he --
and he was very generous with his
praise, but he did say it has to be,
there has to be more
presence on the page.
I was just using Alpheus music
writer pencils, but he wanted me
to press into the paper a lot more.
And I was using a ruler,
which helped.
But it just had to be, it just
had to look more forceful.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did this
change your relationship?
Did he start of start thinking
of you in a different way?
>> Charlie Harmon: I don't know
how, well, the working relationship
at the beginning I just
thought was kind of odd
because I didn't know
anything about him.
I didn't know that
he smoked cigarettes.
I didn't know he had been
married and had kids.
And I remember one day somebody
named Alexander called and I said,
well, you know, I'll take a message.
And Lenny screamed at me, he said,
that's my son, don't
you know anything?
And I said, I didn't
know you had a son.
So after that when Alexander called
I said, yeah, well, here's your son
on the phone, but I
didn't know that.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did
you call him Lenny?
>> Charlie Harmon: No,
I never called him Lenny
until after he died.
I always called him Maestro or LB.
>> Mark Horowitz: And he
never encouraged you to?
>> Charlie Harmon: No, and it's
funny because when I worked
for Lorin Maiazel as a freelance
editor, he liked to be called Lorin,
but I mean talk about
a grand personality,
I mean the opposite of Bernstein.
But I also ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Which was grand?
>> Charlie Harmon:
Oh, Lorin Maiazel.
>> Mark Horowitz: Really?
>> Charlie Harmon: But he liked
to be called Lorin, he liked to be
on a first name basis
with everybody.
Yeah, it was -- he
was very different
from Bernstein, that's for sure.
>> Mark Horowitz: One thing,
it had never occurred to me
when you were talking about
the conducting it seemed most
of it was focused on
recording and I'd sort
of assumed it was mostly
focused on concerts
for audiences and that's ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, but
all his recordings were live,
always does ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Studio recordings?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, the West
Side Story album with Te Kanawa,
Jose Carreras, and Tatiana.
>> Mark Horowitz: For that?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yes, and actually
that had an unforeseen benefit.
It was kind of a disaster.
I mean it wasn't --
Carreras was not the tenor
that Bernstein had requested, and
I guess, was it Neil Rosenshein --
I can't remember who was the
tenor -- wasn't available.
And so a little committee was put
together, and I was not involved
in this at all, and they had to
find a tenor and they latched
on to Carreras, who said yes.
But nobody sent him any music,
and then his luggage
went somewhere else.
So he arrived in New York
completely unprepared and kind
of upset that he had no clothes.
Meanwhile, I was a little
concerned about the music copying
because it was the original
materials being used
for this recording.
And the crew, the editorial crew
that was put together wanted
to come meet with Bernstein and talk
about the discrepancies they found.
And I think they said they
found 1,500 errors in the parts
and another 1,500 in the score.
And what Bernstein did,
they came to the Dakota
and I showed them into the study.
Bernstein put some ice in some
glasses and Ballantine's on the ice
and handed each of the guys
a drink, and then he talked
and he wouldn't let
them ask any questions.
So nothing got fixed, and it was a
mess, it was really, really a mess.
And at one point in that film
by Humphrey Burton of the making
of this recording, he turns around
and he chews out the editorial crew.
And there was nothing
that they could do,
he wouldn't answer their questions.
I read a book, I sat in
the back and read a book.
It was an awful three
days, it was really no fun.
But the good thing about that
is that Candide was going
to be the next project, which we
did with the London Symphony in '89,
actually almost a year
before Bernstein died.
And Bernstein said, well, there
needs to be just one person
in charge of putting
the music together.
And he said, Charlie
has to do it, so I did.
Harry was very skeptical
that I could handle that,
and it took me about six months.
I worked with the Hershy
Kay orchestration pages
that are now here at the library
because that was all that existed.
I didn't so much erase anything,
except if Hershy Kay had written
say the second violins doubled the
second clarinet, for awhile he
would just write call clarinet 2,
so I would erase that
and write the notes in.
Because what I had to --
oh, and there were no lyrics in
the Hershy Kay orchestration pages.
So I put in all the lyrics, I made
the dynamics match up and down,
and occasionally there
would be just a blank bar
and I figured Hershy Kay had gone
to get a sandwich or something
and come back and forgotten, you
know, that the tuba would just be --
the first part of the page
the tuba would be playing
and then it would be blank, and
obviously was supposed to play.
When I -- and the harp in Bon
Voyage plays for the first four bars
and then is tacit for
something like 390 bars,
and I forgot to bring
that up with Bernstein.
There really should be
a harp in that number.
But then Bernstein reviewed
with me page by page the score
that I had put together,
and then I produced a set
of hand copied parts for it.
And then we had a full day
with the London Symphony.
Justin Brown was hired to
be Assistant Conductor.
Running through all the material
with just the orchestra to see
if there were any problems, and
there were a couple wrong notes
but it worked, it was great.
I also made sure all the singers
had their, you know, every,
every number including the
26 additional bars he put,
he reinstated into the
Odudifey [Assumed Spelling],
excellent chorus, the London
Voices, beautifully prepared.
And it worked, it came
together really well.
And it was a year after that
Candide that he asked me
to be his Music Editor,
but he said that was ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Your
title changed at that point?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yes, and ...
>> Mark Horowitz: And how long
were you then Music Editor?
>> Charlie Harmon: Then, well, he
died, so I did it for nine years.
So I worked for him for
a total of 18 years,
four years as his Assistant,
three basically to be,
to put that archive together,
which was really more
of an appraisal than
making an archive.
We just, we didn't know what was
in that apartment in the Osborne.
And then a year as working
on Candide, basically,
and then nine years
as his Music Editor.
After his death.
>> Mark Horowitz: Again, I thought
a lot about him editing his scores,
but I don't know in terms of
the recordings, themselves,
how involved he was with listening
to them, editing the recordings,
approving things there, what was
that like, how did that work?
>> Charlie Harmon: That,
for me that was an education
because I had never
attended a recording session.
And it was always the same
crew, headed by Hans Weber
from Deutsche Grammophon.
And the technicians, there was kind
of a rotating group of technicians,
but it was basically six
or seven guys who were --
I mean and Lenny loved them,
I mean he just absolutely adored
this crew, especially Hans Weber.
But then there were these approval
sessions in which the edited tapes,
you know, they'd have to splice out
a really bad cough from somewhere
in the audience or let's say, well,
with the Vienna Philharmonic
there were some recordings
that were just one take
because they play perfectly.
And, you know, that happened
with other orchestras, too,
the New York Philharmonic did that.
But, in fact, the first recording
session I went to with Bernstein was
at Watford [Assumed
Spelling] Town Hall,
the BBC Symphony Orchestra
doing an all Elgar album,
and there were these marches
that the live concert was enigma
variations and Bernstein songfest.
And so the enigma was taken
from the live performance,
but at the recording session
at Watford Town Hall the album was
being filled out with Elgar marches.
And I remember in the car
going up to Watford I said,
how is it that this orchestra
is going to just play these
and record them without
any rehearsal?
We're doing, you know, six
or seven marches in one day.
And Bernstein said, well,
they've played these before.
[laughter] They know
these, this music,
and they're going to watch me.
And he said, just pay attention
at this recording session
and you'll see how it's done.
And it was done, it was incredible.
And they're good, they're fabulous
recordings of those Elgar marches,
of the Crown of India and Pomp
and Circumstance and
all those standards.
But then there was still an approval
session and when there was a piece
that had several performances and
sometimes a little bit of retakes,
the audience would sit there in
the hall because the ambiance had
to be the same, and there would
be maybe the end of one movement,
just three or four bars that
Hans Weber would say, well,
we heard someone shuffling in
their seat or something like that,
we heard a creaking seat,
or the second bassoon wasn't
really paying attention
or something like that.
I'm just making things up.
So there would be splices and then
there would be a listening session
maybe six months later.
And Bernstein and Hans Weber
would compare notes without,
I mean neither of them had anything
written but Bernstein would say, oh,
so that was the Sunday
morning concert,
the end of that movement was
from the Sunday morning concert,
even though you used the Saturday
afternoon for most of that movement.
And Hans Weber would say, yes,
yes, that's exactly right.
They remembered all this.
>> Mark Horowitz: How did
Lenny actually edit his scores?
What was the process of ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Something he
learned from Koussevitzky was
to mark the phrasing at the top
of the page with a blue pencil,
a curve for a three-bar phrase,
and the top of a triangle,
like a gable on a house,
for a two-bar phrase,
and then if it was more than, more
bars than that you could draw,
say in Haydn when there
are five-bar phrases,
you draw the three-bar phrase and
then you put a plus, four plus five,
and it's just a reminder, it's a
conductor's note and it's a reminder
of where the music is
going, you know, what --
as though you were an actor reading
a soliloquy from Shakespeare,
you want to know where the phrase
ends so you can take a breath
or emphasize something new.
But then with red pencil he'd
mark, especially articulation,
lots and lots of articulation,
sometimes just making it consistent
within a score and sometimes it was
the matter of a not great edition
or an older edition or
the original edition and,
but sometimes a real change.
I remember in a Moller 9, I
think, must be in the Burlesque,
there's an upward scale passage
for almost the entire orchestra,
but there's also a
retard in that scale.
And what Bernstein did was to
alter the rhythmic notation
so that the retard would happen
pretty much automatically from,
let's say, 16th equal 16th notes
to, let's say, a triplet of 16ths
with the last one tied
to an 8th note,
and then the orchestra would
play it absolutely accurately
and then it would be
that automatic change
of tempo that he was looking for.
And that's something
that you can do in music.
You don't want to tell everybody in
the audience that you're doing that.
[laughter] But I mean
Moller did it to Beethoven.
>> Mark Horowitz: But how
would he make those decisions?
Did they evolve over time?
Would he play something,
conduct something one way once
and then decide that
worked or that didn't work?
>> Charlie Harmon: He was
constantly rethinking every piece
that he conducted.
And I remember at the
last concert at Tanglewood
when he was doing Beethoven 7 he --
I'd never seen a conductor do this
and I've seen it now over
and over -- talking to the --
as he was rehearsing talking
to the orchestra over the music
and telling them things and
praising them when they did well.
But, for instance, in
the second movement
of the Beethoven 7 the winds come
in at one point on a 7th chord,
it's not -- it's there's
a long phrase, but the --
and there are no woodwinds and
then the winds come in on a chord
that is going to resolve eventually
at the end of this phrase,
that was very new, nobody
did it before Beethoven.
And Lenny was talking ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Before Beethoven?
>> Charlie Harmon: Before Beethoven.
>> Mark Horowitz: Okay.
Okay.
>> Charlie Harmon: And so Lenny
was talking to the Boston Symphony
about this particular chord
and that Brahms used it,
borrowed that from
Beethoven, and you hear it
in the Brahms symphonies, you
don't hear it in Mozart or Haydn,
the winds don't come in on a chord
that is just going to hang there.
And so what it does
in the Beethoven --
all this was explained while he was
conducting, during the rehearsal --
what it does in the Beethoven
is it adds to the phrase,
but the winds have to shape
that second half of that phrase
in such a way that it's going
to help the phrase resolve.
It's very beautiful.
So what he got them to do, and I
don't remember if he marked this
in his score, but at least
he told them, was they enter,
the winds enter in the 7th chord,
they expand the sound a little bit
and then they taper off
because then the chord resolves
and everybody plays in a downward
scale to the end of the phrase.
And that's the sort of thing that
a conductor, I mean you really have
to study a score and get
the composer in the context
of where he was in his career and.
>> Mark Horowitz: Would he be
reading biographies of the --
I mean where would he get some
of the musicological background?
>> Charlie Harmon: No, it was
mostly just from reading scores.
He could -- his knowledge,
his perception
in reading a score was phenomenal.
He did read a number -- I mean
he was always reading books.
There were three bookbags
that went on every trip.
There was an interesting biography
of Robert Schumann that came out,
really a psycho-sexual
biography of Schumann
by a guy named Peter Ostwald.
And authors would give
galleys to Bernstein,
so he would get these in advance.
And he expected me to read them,
too, because I mean, you know,
you're going to sit in an airport
changing planes and you're there
for two hours with
nothing to do, well,
you're going to have a
conversation with Leonard Bernstein
about Robert Schumann's
sexual problems
because that's what he
wanted to talk about.
[laughter] So I had
to read the book, too.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did Lenny
listen to other conductors?
Would he get recordings
or go to concerts
and would he ever be
influenced by what they did?
>> Charlie Harmon: Not as
much as people would think.
He usually, when offered,
he would agree to go.
Oh, there were some bad moments.
Sinopoli was doing Moller, a Moller
Cycle also for Deutsche Grammophon.
And we were in Rome one time and
Sinopoli was doing the Moller No.
2 and with the academia of
santachachilia [Assumed Spelling]
and they gave, they
said to Bernstein, well,
you have to come hear
this guy, he's fantastic.
And we'd never heard of him.
And I didn't want to go.
I was working on the orchestra
material for the Beethoven 3rd,
which was being done
the following week,
Bernstein with the same orchestra.
And so Bernstein went to
this concert and his seat was
in the middle of a row and he
realized within a minute-and-a-half
that the performance was a disaster,
that Sinopoli didn't know
how to conduct Moller.
And he wasn't any more specific than
that, but Bernstein said he looked
around and he realized he couldn't
get up and leave, it would be --
and there's no intermission
in that piece.
So he was stuck.
And he came back to the
hotel and I was still up.
We were in a suite where there
were bedrooms at opposite ends
of the suite, and I didn't
always share a suite,
I usually had a very separate room.
And he saw that the light was on
and I was sitting at a little desk,
marking up the Beethoven 3rd
Symphony parts, and he was furious,
he was absolutely furious.
He said he wasted an entire
evening and he never wanted
to hear anything more
about this conductor.
But usually, I mean if he went to
something he was kind of grateful.
He'd go back stage.
What's his name?
Wonderful British conductor, ah, he
always had a cane, younger guy --
Davis, no, I can't
remember his name.
Bernstein would go back stage and,
you know, be worshipful usually,
but not with someone like Sinopoli.
I can say Sinopoli because he died
and his Moller symphonies
didn't sell very well.
[laughter]
>> Mark Horowitz: This
may be a naive question,
but I've been involved in theater
where a director will have the
actors experiment with things,
try things, does a
conductor ever do that?
Let's say, let's see what
happens if you do this or let's --
there's not that kind of
give and take with the ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, that
was Bernstein and especially not
in the last, the last eight years
that I knew him of his life.
He really knew what he wanted.
He may have done that when
he was at the Philharmonic.
There were some experimental
programs.
In fact, Jack Gottlieb and would
talk about that occasionally
because Jack was Bernstein's
assistant during some
of those Philharmonic years.
And Bernstein did tell
me that at one concert
with the Philharmonic it was
all very new experimental stuff
and there was no applause
and he didn't know how
to get off the stage.
[laughter] And so he finally just
put his baton down and slunk off.
>> Mark Horowitz: How much
did he try and find new works?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well,
he didn't have to do much
because there were upwards
of two dozen scores arriving
every week at his apartment.
>> Mark Horowitz: Would he
read through them, though?
>> Charlie Harmon: No, that was part
of my job was to sift through them
and if I felt something was
worthy to put it on his desk.
And I'd say every year
maybe three works.
Sometimes it was it was a famous
name and I felt obligated.
He did ask, though, for instance
when Peter Maxwell Davies wrote
his 8th symphony he said he wanted
to look at it.
Oh, I know, we had
the Fires of London
that was Max Davies
group came to New York.
Bernstein had never heard
the Fires of London.
He knew what they were.
And I got a pair of tickets.
I had met Max Davies a number of
years before, he was doing a US tour
with Corolla Nair [Assumed
Spelling] and a couple other works.
And, oh, I met Max Davies
because when I lived
in Boston I shared an apartment
and my roommate had
been a pupil of Davies.
So we went to this.
I got this -- I got tickets.
There was also, there was a premiere
by Elliott Carter that night.
And so Bernstein met Davies
and he was very impressed,
I mean he thought, yeah,
this guy is the real thing.
Although at the party afterwards
off in a corner I saw Bernstein,
Ned Rom [Assumed Spelling], Elliott
Carter and Max Davies talking
to one another and they
didn't look very happy.
And I thought I would
go over there and see
if anybody needed a
refresher for their drinks.
And what they were discussing was
how they had lost their looks.
[laughter] And I thought, you know,
this incredible congruence of talent
of 20th Century musicians and
that's what they were talking about.
But, so I got some scores
of Davies from Boosie
and Hawks [Assumed Spelling],
but Bernstein never
conducted any of them.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was it awkward
for him, friends who were composers,
like David Diamond, that they would
want him to look at their works
or conduct them and he
would have to say no?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, it was
-- it depended on who it was.
One of the albums that Bernstein
did with the New York Philharmonic
that I helped out on, but it was
after I had stopped being his
Assistant, was a David Dell tratagie
and adrorum [Assumed
Spelling] album.
And Ned's piece was for violin
and orchestra and it's a suite,
I can't remember what the title is.
And Bernstein decided to
reorder the suite, and Ned didn't
like that he did that, but what
are you going to do, you know,
it's a recording by the
New York Philharmonic.
It's going to help
publicize the suite.
And I think eventually --
well, they stayed friends,
I mean they weren't going to
break up, it wasn't going to break
up their friendship, but I think
eventually Bernstein came around
and said, yeah, you were right,
the original order was better.
And he did a terrific recording
of the David Dell trategie piece.
I think it could have been done --
no, it was a piece that wasn't
connected to the Alice books.
But also they would -- all these
composers that he'd known --
I mean he'd known Rorum
[Assumed Spelling]
since the, I think the 1940s.
David, I can't remember when they
would have met, and David Diamond
of course they knew one
another all their lives.
So he was always in touch with them
and they would always send
their scores or a recording,
or a recording and a score.
I remember when the first of the
Halles' [Assumed Spelling] pieces
of deltratachie [Assumed
Spelling] arrived,
and that afternoon
Lenny put on the album
and followed through the score.
And I wasn't -- this
was up in Connecticut,
I was doing something else.
And later that evening Bernstein
said, well, you really should listen
to this thing and look at the score,
you know, you'll learn something.
I couldn't really get into.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was he ever
concerned that other people's music
that he was conducting and listening
to might inadvertently influence
his own writing or that never ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, there
was this other problem he had,
when he conducted Moller of,
for instance, it was very hard
to get the Moller out
of his head and get back
to what he considered Bernstein.
But I don't think the
influence, I think his --
somehow how he had learned music
composition was so accurate
in some way of pinpointing
what was his personality.
I think this was something
he learned from Copland
and Copland learned it from
Nadia Bulange [Assumed Spelling],
that Copland had said that when
he first went to Bulange --
I can't remember the piece he
had, he'd written something,
and she'd say, well, these two bars
that's you, so we need more of that.
And there would be 40 other pages
that were, you know, she'd say, no,
that doesn't mean anything.
And there is some correspondence
between Copland and Bernstein
because everything
that Bernstein wrote
after he met Copland he
would share with Copland
and Copland would do the same thing.
I think, what was the piece, maybe
Jeremiah went through that process,
I think there is some correspondence
here that helps illustrate that.
And Copland did the same thing,
he'd say, well, this section is you,
but all this other stuff
that's somebody else.
And that, when you have a good
instructor or a good mentor
when you're young enough that really
does focus your compositional skill.
>> Mark Horowitz: When he was
working on A Quiet Place how much
of it was setting, text and did
that, you know, was he concerned
about the natural flow of
language, the rhythm and the pitches
of language or they were separate?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, the
language, he and Stephen had this,
I don't want to say agenda
but they definitely wanted
to do an American opera
in the vernacular,
the way people actually speak.
So there are all kinds
of interruptions
and people interrupting one another
and people interrupting themselves.
And there was a big
discussion one week
about whether they could use the
F word in an opera and, in fact,
it is, there's the F word
appears in A Quiet Place.
So there is that aspect, there
was the conscious setting
of an American vernacular.
Musically, I didn't
know it at the time,
but Bernstein constantly recycled
music that he had written for pieces
that either never took off or were
abandoned in some way or other.
So in A Quiet Place I think there
are segments that had been written
for a musical version of the
Nabokov Bocalita [Assumed Spelling]
that he was going to
write with Edward Albee.
I think most of A Quiet Place,
though, is newly composed.
Harmonically it's based on the
harmonic language of Trouble
in Tahiti with a little
bit more abstraction.
And one evening he finished
one of the interludes,
this was up in Connecticut,
there are these interludes
between the acts.
And he couldn't -- he wanted
to play it at the piano,
but he needed two extra hands.
And I was up, I was reading, it
was around three in the morning.
And so he asked me to sit at the
piano with him and play this thing,
and he explained to me as we --
I mean I sat there and
I did what I could.
We got better, we played
it about 10 times,
I mean I got better,
he played perfectly.
But he explained to me how
out of the harmonic language
that he was using for A Quiet Place,
and there was a different harmonic
language for certain other pieces.
Dybbuk is a great example of
a harmonic structure that out
of which the entire piece comes.
There are these scales and
chord combinations that are --
it's not like serialism
because it's more --
there's more emotion
involved in that and more
about what can be caught
by the listener.
I think serialism is not
so much about listening,
but it's just how it
looks on the page.
But with A Quiet Place
he was explaining how
out of the harmony he derives the
melodic contours that he wants.
And, of course, it's based on the
emphasis of speech and rhythms
and the rhythms had to be exactly
what a vernacular rhythm would be.
And it was quite an instruction.
And so that's really
what A Quiet Place does,
it puts the vernacular into it.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was there
a tension with him of wanting
to do something musically
and at the same time wanting
to do the vernacular and they
would never be in conflict or?
>> Charlie Harmon: I think for him
that was the way he always
had wanted to compose,
and I think his first stab at that
was probably Trouble in Tahiti.
But actually I think a really good
example of that is Wonderful Town.
I think Wonderful Town
is very vernacular,
even though it's got some --
what's -- a song like A Quiet Girl,
which was actually written
for [inaudible] for Jamie.
It's very singerly, but
still it works as a kind
of vernacular number
and it's never stilted.
In everything, the emphasis --
well, there is something that
Sondheim talks about when somewhere
from West Side Story has always
been known as the Ah Song.
[laughter] But, for
me, the syllable, ah,
leads to something else,
a place, but it is ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Is that
something Lenny ever talked about?
Did he, was he self-conscious
about that at all, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: No, I actually
never talked to him about --
I didn't talk, I had never even
seen West Side Story when I worked
for him, I had never seen the film.
My mother wouldn't let me go see it.
>> Mark Horowitz: You've
heard the score?
>> Charlie Harmon: I'd
heard two numbers from it
because when I was a teenager
I bought an album that said,
Highlights of Broadway from
whatever year, in the 50s.
And so the Jet song and
America were on this album.
It was one of those
composite albums with cuts
from various original cast albums.
And I loved the Jet song because it
didn't sound like show music to me,
it sounded completely other.
And talk about vernacular, I mean
that's wonderfully vernacular.
But I didn't know the show at all,
and the first time I saw it I
sat next to Bernstein at the --
you know, I was his Assistant,
I had to sit next to him --
at a London revival in
'84 I think, maybe '85.
It was a wonderful production.
Tommy Abbott, who had been Geetar
in the original, was the --
who had recreated the choreography.
And Bernstein, as he always did,
talked all the way
through the performance.
I didn't take notes, but
I remember what he said.
It was like a private master
class, and it just happened
to be his biggest, you
know, his splashiest piece.
It was an unforgettable evening.
Mostly he would say
things like, I mean he --
when the conductor would speed
up too much he'd put his hand,
Bernstein would put his hand
like he was putting the brake
on or something like that.
And he told the conductor
afterwards to trust the music more.
[laughter]
>> Mark Horowitz: What about working
with a choreographer
in terms of the music?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, I don't,
you know, in the years I worked
for him there wasn't
any choreography.
I don't think that there was any.
And I didn't know anything
about ballet or dance at all,
and he was horrified that I'd
never really been to a ballet.
I think I saw one ballet
when I lived in Naples.
Ballet has never really
interested me that much.
Well, for one thing the music
tends to be pretty silly, you know.
You go to Don Quixote, the Pettipop
[Assumed Spelling] production
of this music by Mincus [Assumed
Spelling] really is ridiculous.
So what Bernstein started doing
when I would have a free night
and he knew that something, that
there would be a Robbins' revival
at City Ballet he would call up
and get me a ticket
and insist that I go.
And then after the performance I had
to go back to the Dakota and talk
to Bernstein about what I saw.
You know, how did it
work with the music?
Because when there was an
interesting revival Bernstein,
himself, would often go, especially
if Robbins was touching up,
you know, making sure that the
dancers really were following
his instructions.
And he said that for Stars and
Stripes Robbins invited him up on
to the catwalk above the stage,
and so they watched the
performance from up in the catwalk.
And he said that's a complete,
it's a dazzling way to look
at how a choreographer thinks
about placement on the stage.
He said you just can't believe how
it changes how you look at dance.
I said, well, you know, lucky
for you, that's terrific.
[laughter] So the first
thing I got to see
of Robbins was the Debussy
Prelude to an Afternoon,
it takes place in a dance studio.
I just didn't know
what to make of it.
So I went back to the Dakota and
I said, well, here's what I liked,
because I had learned long ago
when giving a criticism
you say three good things
and then you can say whatever you
want about what you didn't like,
but you have to start
with three good things.
And I don't remember ...
>> Mark Horowitz: With
Lenny or just in general?
>> Charlie Harmon: In general,
I would never give criticism
without saying three good
things, and if I couldn't think
of three things I'd say, well,
I just can't say anything.
[laughter] And so we
talked for about an hour
about this particular
ballet of Robbins.
And Bernstein knew it
backwards and forwards
and he understood exactly
what Robbins was trying to do
and what all the names were of
all the classical movements.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did he
have a photographic memory?
>> Charlie Harmon: You know, the
visuals for him were kind of strange
because he didn't know
anything about painting.
When we were in Madrid one time
and we had a twelve o'clock flight
to Barcelona he got up early the
day we were leaving and he said --
we were at the Ritz, which is
right, the back garden goes right
to the Prado, and he said
do we have time to go
over to the Prado before
we get into the car?
And I said, yeah, we can go,
but I said I'm going to take you
to just, to one painting.
And the Las Meninas, the
Handmaidens of Velasquez,
was in a separate room at that time.
I think it had just been cleaned.
So I took him in there, and he
didn't know what he was looking at.
And I explained, I'd read all
kinds of essays about this painting
and I explained who everybody was
and how the painting was organized
and colors and structure and light.
And he was really fascinated, but
he'd never, he never even thought
about that in terms of
looking at a painting.
So it was odd, it was odd.
But he loved dance.
I don't know what the
big draw was, though.
He loved talking to
Robbins about choreography.
But, yeah, while I was working
for him there wasn't anything
that was choreographed.
>> Mark Horowitz: When he was both
composing and conducting did he work
at a piano or to what degree did he?
>> Charlie Harmon:
Conducting was only at a desk.
>> Mark Horowitz: So he wouldn't
go and see if there was an ...
>> Charlie Harmon:
No, very, very rarely.
No, and he really didn't have
to rely on a piano for that.
For composing it was a mix, it was a
-- Fairfield was the perfect setup,
his house in Connecticut,
where he had the grand piano,
a big flat desk.
I mean, you know, you could put --
well, the paper was pretty much 11
by 17, but you could put
four pieces of paper.
And then a stand-up desk, like
-- something like what Jefferson,
Thomas Jefferson had, with an angle,
very long, six or eight feet long,
so you could put page after
page next to one another.
And I was thinking of that
yesterday when I was looking
at manuscripts here, it's
very easy to tell for me
when something was written at the
piano, there's a kind of shakiness.
It looks more like an older guy's
script, but it isn't necessarily
that he was older, he was just
writing like this at the piano.
And then go to the flat desk to make
the fair copy, rewrite it completely
from start to finish, but
that was only when he was sure
that he had a segment
that was a real entity.
And the stand-up desk
was for the corrections
or making yet another copy.
Sometimes there would be two
fair copies of the same piece.
There would be an insert and then
he would want to put that in.
Although when I was looking
at Dybbuk yesterday there
were an awful lot of inserts
that simply got, it's the next
page, and you have to know to go
to that page and then come back.
And then some of the paper that
he was using was this fold --
what do you call that when it's
two pages that are folded together,
not a fold -- well, maybe
it is called a folio.
And then one of those folded
pages would become the folder
for that number.
And every piece he wrote
is in discrete numbers,
and then on the front of the folder
you put whatever the title is
or if it doesn't have
a title it's just
where it goes in the larger work.
And everything for that
number goes into that folder,
any little envelope on which
he's written thoughts or a change
in lyrics or something like
that it goes into that folder.
And so all of his works
were organized in that way.
But that's all done piano and desk.
Conducting was completely,
completely other.
>> Mark Horowitz: The collection,
as you know, is so huge.
How much of it was saved because of
his own sense of posterity or was it
because of Helen Coates, was
it a combination, was it --
you know, and not -- the music
manuscripts sort of, of course,
but the fact that they saved
all the fan mail or ...
>> Charlie Harmon: You
know, I never talked to him
about the posterity aspect.
Helen probably felt that
weight of posterity.
I think she must have
recognized even
from the very first piano
lesson that he had with her
that this was a talent that
would actually go somewhere.
And, yeah, she certainly saved
every, every piece of fan mail.
I had the feeling that
Bernstein saved his manuscripts
so that he could refer
to them later.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did
he do that that you saw?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, there were,
especially with A Quiet Place
there were previous manuscripts
that he would want to look at,
and then there would be
little individual numbers.
Ah, there was a number about --
he wrote, I wouldn't call
it a cabaret song but a kind
of a throwaway song called,
I Wish I Had Never Gone
to That Party, and
I couldn't find it.
He asked me what happened
to this song he had written,
and I never found it.
It actually may be here, but I --
that's beyond what I can look at.
But he liked to have these things
kept track of because rather
than write them out from
memory again it was just useful
to have as a reference.
>> Mark Horowitz: But
there was an ego there?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah,
but we never talked
about the posterity aspect.
>> Mark Horowitz: Somebody once said
to me he suffered from
importantitis.
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, it's true
that everything he uttered he felt
was going to be earthshattering,
of great importance, and that
people should pay attention
to what he was -- but then he
thought consciously before he would
say things, although he never
went on to Cavett or any
of those talk shows because he
was afraid he would put his foot
in his mouth, say something that
he -- well, would be misunderstood,
not that he hadn't intended but
that would be misunderstood.
>> Mark Horowitz: And he
actually verbalized that to you,
that that's why he didn't do that?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yes,
that's why he didn't do it.
He never went on a talk show,
plus his language was a
little colorful and, you know,
it just would have been bleeped out
and that would have
been embarrassing.
I mean back then there, you know,
a series of leaps people would
have turned off their TV.
>> Mark Horowitz: But it's
an interesting self-awareness
to have that.
>> Charlie Harmon: He
also, I mean he didn't --
he liked to be carefully prepared,
everything he did was
actually carefully --
he was a student all of his
life, he really studied scores
that he was going to conduct,
when he had to give a speech,
went through seven drafts.
The Young People's
Concerts, an enormous amount
of preparation for each script.
It was all about being prepared.
>> Mark Horowitz: As he got old,
or you talked about even the very
first time you met him he sort
of seemed, from what I can tell, to
become somewhat dissolute and did
that not influence the other,
was he able to compartmentalize?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, there
was definitely that ability
to shift gears, it was pretty
remarkable how he was able
to do that.
Dissolute, yeah, there is
definitely some dissolution.
Sometimes a self-indulgence that
veered into being out of control.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was there
self-awareness about that?
Was there embarrassment?
Would he try and then
rein himself in, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: I don't think
he understood what was necessary.
For instance, at the end of
the first year that I worked
for him he wasn't sleeping.
He'd taken a lot of -- well,
for me, it looked like a lot
of Dexedrine over that year.
And it was something older
guys did in the 70s and 80s,
they took Dexedrine for energy.
I don't think -- well, I don't
know if anybody does that now,
but it definitely keeps you awake.
And he wasn't getting any sleep.
So Harry Kraut looked into
a sleep disorder clinic.
And over one particular weekend
in November of '82 Bernstein went
to the Montefiore Sleep-Wake
Disorder Clinic
and it was discovered he had what
is actually a pretty normal sleep
pattern of seven hours
and then 17 hours awake.
But he never learned about preparing
for the seven hours of sleep.
I mean, you know, a couple
drinks before dinner, a big --
well, not necessarily a rich meal,
but a fairly big meal at the end
of the day, a chocolate bar
just before going to bed.
He didn't drink after
dinner, particularly,
and he didn't drink
much with dinner.
And then, you know, a midnight
phone call from his sister, Shirley.
Whenever he was on the phone
he had to smoke a cigarette,
so he'd have three or four
cigarettes while on the phone
with Shirley discussing
crossword puzzles.
Then his brain would be going, you
know, a million miles a minute,
finishing the crossword puzzle
in the Guardian and being hyped
up from having smoked
a few cigarettes.
And it would be two in the morning,
and then he would say, well,
you know, I'm not tired, so I'm
going to stay up and I'm going
to work on this piece of music.
And on some pieces he
wrote the time of day,
if he got to a double bar line
he'd write the time of day.
I think Puccini did this, also.
And it's often three or four a.m.
[laughter] Well, and then go to bed.
>> Mark Horowitz: But, why, what was
the importance of marking the time?
>> Charlie Harmon: Oh, it was
just keeping track, I think.
Although, for me, a piece he gave
me called, One Minute for Charlie,
I think it's 3:10 a.m. at
the double bar at the end.
I think it was to show, see,
I stayed up all night
writing this for you.
[laughter] But, and then -- and
then realized that it was, you know,
it was late and if he had a
commitment the next day he was going
to have to get up at some point.
So how was he going to fall asleep?
Well, you take a sleeping pill,
but if you take it 15 minutes before
you go to bed it doesn't take affect
for an hour so he's up for an hour.
And then, you know, ends up
sleeping until two in the afternoon.
It was just, it was really ...
>> Mark Horowitz: Would he
miss appointments sometimes?
>> Charlie Harmon:
No, but there was --
the first time I was at
Tanglewood with him we --
he would tell me, I would
wake him up let's say at eight
in the morning, and
he'd say, oh, you know,
cross-out the 10 a.m. I said,
I'll make the one o'clock
conducting class, but that thing
at 10 a.m. just cross it out.
So I'd call Richard Ortner
[Assumed Spelling] and say, well,
we're not going to be there at 10
o'clock or whatever the heck it was,
but we'll be at Saranac [Assumed
Spelling] at one in the afternoon.
And he regretted doing that.
It got worse as the years
went on, but it was just --
he never really put it
all together in terms
of how you prepare to go to sleep.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did you
ever try and explain any
of these things to him, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: No, because I
wasn't the medical professional
and he needed to talk to
someone who was a professional.
So the doctor at the
Sleep-Wake Clinic got him
to adjust to this schedule.
It was mayhem for several weeks
because we were moving his
schedule I think two hours a day,
so that it would eventually be that
he would go to sleep at something
like one in the morning, but then
be up by eight o'clock the next day.
But to get to that meant that
we were moving the schedule,
and he was -- well, of
course, it was all about him,
so he loved that he was doing
this and we were all, you know,
his whole household staff
was involved in this.
It would be nine o'clock at
night, he would be getting
up because we were moving
the schedule for him,
and he'd come downstairs and
say to Julio [Assumed Spelling],
the housekeeper, I'm ready
for a bowl of oatmeal.
And she'd say, of course, Senor, and
make him a bowl of oatmeal at nine,
whereas, we had just
finished dinner.
[laughter] And so the goal was that
by Thanksgiving, November of '82,
he would be on a normal schedule.
And it worked, it worked, it
worked for about two months
and then he just didn't
pay any attention to it,
he went back to his old habits.
Oh, and he also had to keep
track, just like with smokers,
he had to keep track of how he
felt across the course of the day,
whether he felt like he needed a
nap, you know, was he indulging
in sugar or alcohol
or anything like that.
>> Mark Horowitz: This
was for his doctor?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, for
the sleep disorder doctor,
not for his normal doctor.
>> Mark Horowitz: To
what degree did he --
I mean faith seems to have been
such an important part of his work
and all that, but did
he go to show regularly,
did he do religious things or
that was just an internal thing?
>> Charlie Harmon: There were -- one
of the first things he told me was
that on Friday, Friday evening
he would call his mother
and it didn't matter where we
were or what was going on he had
to call his mother every Friday.
And that, that to me
that meant something.
But, no, one Yom Kippur we were
in London and so he was invited
to the Marble Arch
Synagogue and he went.
I was really grateful because
then I had a free night.
And the next night we went to that
performance of West Side Story,
so I was recovered enough so that
I could actually pay attention.
I never went with him to any temple,
but I also remember that in Herona,
Spain there are these,
there was a couple --
ah, I don't remember their names --
they were researching the very
ancient Jewish presence in Catalonia
and they had found the
remnants of a synagogue.
And Bernstein went to visit
them and got very emotional
about the Jewish connection
in that part of Spain.
And there are photos
somewhere of him praying
in this kind of subterranean
chamber.
I wasn't with him on that trip.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did
he believe in God?
Did he believe in an afterlife?
Did he ...
>> Charlie Harmon: I
don't think he did,
but that would be conjecture
on my part.
Strangely enough, I think the place
where he was least
religious was Israel.
He kind of chafed.
One time we were flying, we were
taking the Israel Philharmonic
to the May Festival in Florence,
Italy and in order to get
to Florence for a Saturday
evening performance we had
to leave Israel sometime on
Friday, but it wasn't clear
that we could all get to the hotels
in Florence before sunset on Friday.
So the members of the
Israel Philharmonic came
up to Lenny individually and said,
it's not me, it's everybody else
in the orchestra who won't
fly on Friday after sunset.
And after about the tenth person
confessing this Lenny said, oh,
you know, we'll get a dispensation.
And, in fact, the orchestra
did get a special dispensation
from the Grand Rabbi of Rome.
He wasn't interested in the
religious rules that were going
to interfere with getting a
performance done, you know,
a trip followed by a performance.
That was -- I thought that
was a pretty amusing dilemma.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did he fear death?
Would he talk about that?
>> Charlie Harmon: There was one
phase that started appearing I think
in the third year I
was working for him,
was the Maestro said just before
he died, you know, he would --
he'd be telling me to do something
and then he'd stick in a joke.
I mean there were constant
jokes, so that everything was --
if I didn't have a new joke
every day then he wasn't going
to pay any attention to me.
>> Mark Horowitz: You had
to collect jokes for him?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, they're
written in a kind of a shorthand
in the back of my date books.
Anytime I heard a new
joke I wrote it down.
And then what I learned
to do was to --
whenever he told me a joke I would
retell it immediately and try
to embellish it because you
always had to embellish whatever,
and so that this repertoire
of jokes became just part
of daily conversation.
But, yes, absolutely, there had
to be new jokes all the time.
So, oh, yes, so after
a joke he would say,
and then the Maestro
said just before he died.
[laughter] And that was
supposed to be funny.
That was, it was an indication that
he was feeling mortal, I think.
He also began singing,
and this was --
I remember the first time he sang
this, something that I had learned
as a little kid -- where will
we be in 100 years from now,
pushing up the daisies,
pushing up the daisies.
[laughter] Chopin's funeral march,
I mean that's pretty morbid.
>> Mark Horowitz: Were there
things that he desperately wanted
to accomplish before
he died that he was,
that you had a sense there was a ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, there was
an opera based on the Holocaust,
I think that would
have been interesting
and he really did want to do that.
>> Mark Horowitz: Why
didn't it happen?
>> Charlie Harmon:
There was collaboration,
the collaboration never
came together.
He really wanted to record Macado.
>> Mark Horowitz: Really?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, it
would have been wonderful.
Deutsche Grammophon didn't
know what it was, basically.
I used to poke fun at the big wigs
at Deutsche Grammophon, you know,
yes, for Macado we will have such
[inaudible] soprano for yum yum,
Burket Nielsen [Assumed Spelling].
[laughter] He wanted
to record Othello.
He wanted to do Don Carlos
at the Escarole [Assumed
Spelling] filmed by Zeffirelli.
That was a -- that would have
been a very exciting project.
And just never came together.
And Zeffirelli got
very excited about it.
>> Mark Horowitz: How much power
did Deutsche Grammophon have
or how much did he have with them?
>> Charlie Harmon: That's a good
-- that was a Harry Kraut question.
I don't know, I don't know.
They seemed to dictate the
repertoire that they wanted.
I mean they had actually scheduled
Elijah of Mendelsohn for 1991
and it didn't happen,
obviously, but Elijah.
I mean, gosh, there's
so much else to record.
>> Mark Horowitz: Could he say no?
>> Charlie Harmon: I
don't think he ever did.
I'm not aware that he ever said no.
I was after him, the
Vienna Philharmonic wanted
to do Histroda Sidot [Assumed
Spelling] and they wanted
to do a really interesting program,
especially interesting for them,
Histroda Sidot and maybe the Gran
Partita of Mozart [inaudible].
And, God, there was a third piece,
maybe Requit denot [Assumed
Spelling], I can't remember.
It was a really interesting program
and for them very,
very off-the-wall.
I mean the Vienna Philharmonic
just doesn't do Stravinsky.
And he got excited about
that, but it, you know,
can't get the recording company
behind it it's just not going
to happen.
Yeah, the Othello and the Macado
were very important to him.
>> Mark Horowitz: You just reminded
me, the story you had told me
about the date books, and I don't
know if it's in your memoir,
so if it's not I'd want to
get it down that you would put
in the schedules in
advance so he would see ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Right.
>> Mark Horowitz: ...
but then he would write in ...
>> Charlie Harmon: Yes, I always put
in every concert with every piece
and the time and the hall because he
looked at his date book every day.
In fact, when we -- after
Bloomington, Indiana,
we got back to New York, and
I decided I would continue
with the job, the first
day in New York he said,
the first thing you
have to do when you get
to the apartment every day
is look at my date book.
Because he would be on the phone
at two in the morning and agree
to go have dinner with somebody
and he'd write it in his date book,
everything was very carefully
notated in his date book.
But then what I would do
once I got a tour schedule
or let's say we were going to
Vienna for two weeks I would write
in all the concerts, any
press events that I knew
about or anything like that.
And when we did a tour with
the Bavarian Radio Symphony,
we went to Budapest, Zagreb and
Ljubljana, there were supposed
to be encores but they
hadn't been settled on.
Eventually he did two numbers from
his Divertimento [Assumed Spelling],
he did the Turkey Trot, the Waltz
and the Turkey Trot as encores.
So at the bottom of each program
I just wrote encore, colon,
and he decided to write in the most
stultifying pieces he could think
of, well, the most
ridiculous encores.
Something by John Cage, ah, I can't
remember the title, it was a piece
of John Cage's I had never heard
of, but you would never do John Cage
as an encore after the Schumann
2nd Symphony, I mean really,
and Bartok music for strings,
percussion [inaudible] yeah,
do a piece by John Cage.
But another encore was
the Meditation from Tales
of Massoney [Assumed Spelling].
[laughter]
>> Mark Horowitz: So he
did this to amuse you?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, and
no one else was ever going
to see what was in his date book.
The third concert he wrote in
as encore, Ravelle Deafness
and Chloe Full Ballet
[Assumed Spelling].
[laughter]
>> Mark Horowitz: But so
researchers now looking
at his date books will think these
are the encores he's performed.
>> Charlie Harmon: Exactly,
and I think that's hilarious.
[laughter] So you'd have to go
to the actual concert program.
I don't know if the encores ever
got printed in those programs.
But, yeah, I thought that
was actually pretty funny.
And I haven't really noticed
those until four years ago
when I was looking at
those date books again
and I saw those encore
spoofs, as they were.
I was pretty amused, but
that was a wonderful tour.
>> Mark Horowitz: When he talked
with his mother Friday nights how
long would the conversations last
and what would they talk about?
>> Charlie Harmon:
Probably 15 to 30 minutes.
Well, she would say,
have you stopped smoking?
[laughter] And I talked to
her a couple times a week.
>> Mark Horowitz: Really?
>> Charlie Harmon: After I met her
we talked pretty constantly, yeah.
And if we got someplace,
let's say we got to Vienna
and we hadn't really been in
touch with anybody for a few days,
sometimes I would call Shirley,
especially if Shirley, his sister,
would be up in Connecticut,
I would just call her there.
And she was always very grateful
to hear that, but to call Jennie,
that was special, and
we would talk about --
I would tell her where we
were and what we were doing.
And she'd say, well, is he
cutting back on the cigarettes?
What can we do to get him
to stop, to stop smoking?
And I'd just have to say, well, I'm
not sure that I can do anything.
And, of course, I would --
I sent postcards and if
we saw something that,
or if I saw something
that I thought she would
like I would send it to her.
One time in Key West we sent --
this was Patty Pilloliam's
[Assumed Spelling] idea --
we went to a tropical fruit market
and we packed up a box of, you know,
star fruit and mangoes and papayas
and passion fruit and all kinds
of stuff and grapefruit, and shipped
it by air to Jennie in Boston.
And she loved getting
stuff like that.
I don't think she could
eat all of that.
>> Mark Horowitz: Did Lenny know
you were doing these things?
>> Charlie Harmon: He -- I think he
was a little surprised how much I
was in touch with his mother.
And if he came into -- at the Dakota
if he came into the office and I was
on the phone with her
he wouldn't interrupt,
but afterwards he would say, well,
now what were you talking about?
And I'd say, well, how to
get you to stop smoking.
[laughter] And he didn't
want to hear that.
And then after I quit
being his Assistant I went
up to Boston periodically, whenever
there was a new CD out I would go
up to Boston, I'd take Jennie
and her sisters out for lunch,
give her the CD, organize
what she had.
And one day she called
me and she said,
you know that clothes hamper
that's at the foot of my bed?
I couldn't really remember.
She said, well, I was
emptying it the other day,
I decided I should take
everything out of it,
and you know what I found?
I found a score of Jeremiah.
And I said, oh, come on?
And she said, yeah, it's
always been in there.
[laughter] And she said, I
think you should have this.
Yeah, okay, that's a good idea.
So I flew up there the next day and,
sure enough, it was the manuscript
of I guess just of Lamentation
that he had submitted
to a composition contest and
she had kept it and forgotten
that she'd put it in the
bottom of her clothes hamper.
>> Mark Horowitz: For years.
>> Charlie Harmon: Oh, decades.
[laughter] But I was
so grateful, you know,
because I had this friendship
with her that she felt she --
she wasn't embarrassed about it,
in particular, but she knew that at
that point that it had some value
and that somebody should have it,
somebody should take it off
her hands and I was the one.
>> Mark Horowitz: And how often
did Lenny talk to Shirley?
>> Charlie Harmon: Oh,
it was every night.
>> Mark Horowitz: Really?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, yeah,
especially about crossword
puzzles and about other things.
I mean they would -- also,
Shirley had the roster of jokes,
the repertoire of jokes, new jokes.
And also about show
business and other things,
just gossip about show business.
>> Mark Horowitz: Would he
talk to [inaudible] much, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: Yeah, there
was a lot of conversation
with BB [Assumed Spelling],
as he's called.
Not as much as with Shirley
because with Shirley it was really
about the crossword puzzles and the
puzzles in Harper's and The Atlantic
and also just plain gossip.
>> Mark Horowitz: The focus on games
and jokes, he didn't think of them
as time away from more
important things, or?
>> Charlie Harmon:
No, they almost are
like jumpstarting the
imagination sometimes.
But also the joke telling had a
kind of rabbinical quality to it
because if he told a joke,
especially if there was a new person
in a particular group, he would
tell the joke and then point
to the one person who hadn't said
anything and say, now you retell it.
And there was one very complicated
joke, I'm not going to tell it now,
but it deals with a guy
with a cleft palate.
It's not derogatory, but it is --
it's, you have to imitate
someone with a cleft palate.
But it's complicated, it's
really complicated and you have
to pay attention when
the joke is being told
and it actually is
pretty funny at the end.
But then he would turn to
the person who was, you know,
shy and make them retell it.
And inevitably it would
be all screwed up
and then he would insist on, no, no,
no, all right, I'll tell it again
and then you're going to retell it.
And I have saw people
burst into tears
because they just couldn't get
this and then when you're put
on the spot, of course,
it makes it worse.
But it was all part
of being a teacher.
>> Mark Horowitz: Was there
aspects of cruelty to it?
>> Charlie Harmon: He really did
it for love more than anything else
and also for someone who is shy
and not going to participate
in whatever the camaraderie was
around a table it was trying to get
that person included, also
about using your imagination,
paying attention, remembering
something,
really understanding how a joke
or how a story was structured.
He was really always interested
in how people tell stories
and how thinking and
language come together.
One year, I think it was The
Library of Congress printed
up a calendar illustrated with
Judaica that was from a collection,
and The Library sent
Bernstein this calendar
and he was very impressed by it.
And I remember looking through
it with Bernstein and I said,
Jack would love to have this.
And he signed it and
wrote a note for Jack.
And Jack called me, he was in
tears, he was so thrilled to have
that because they really did discuss
whether shared heritage quite a bit.
>> Mark Horowitz: Okay, I guess
in closing just your thoughts
about your time with Lenny
and how that affected you,
and in retrospect now if your
feelings about him changed
over time, your sense of
his progression at the end?
>> Charlie Harmon: Well, I wish
that I had appreciated more, well,
I wish that the job
hadn't been so grueling.
The last time we were on a
Concord together, as he was sitting
down he said, he was obviously
picking a fight, he said,
you never said anything
good about my Mass.
And I said, well, I've never
seen Mass, I've never --
I know the album, but I've
never seen it performed
and I shouldn't really have --
I can't have an opinion
till I've seen a production.
And spent the whole flight,
he really wanted to argue,
and I tried to steer it
around to what he felt worked
in it and what didn't work.
And I remember sitting
there thinking, you know,
I should be very flattered that
he's having this discussion with me
because who gets to
talk to a composer
of this stature about
a particular work.
And I just didn't know
enough about Mass
to have an interesting discussion.
I was more interested in why
he wanted to pick a fight,
he was in a real foul mood.
And I just wish that I hadn't
been so exhausted all the time
from the job because it would
have been a lot more fun.
To think of him more as a colleague
or as a mentor, and I didn't think
of him that way when
I was working for him.
>> Mark Horowitz: Do you think he
ever thought of you as a friend, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: Eventually.
I took a month off, let's see,
that was after a [inaudible] Place
at L'escola and Harry gave me the
entire month of July of '84 off.
And I came back to the States.
I stayed for a few weeks in Italy,
and I came back to the States.
And the production was at the
Kennedy Center in July of '84,
and I wanted to see one
performance at the Kennedy Center.
So I called the Watergate Hotel and
I was put through to Harry's room,
and I said, you know, I'm just
calling to see how things are.
And Harry invited me
over and said, well,
come up to Lenny's suite
and you can say hello.
And I did, and we -- and Harry
was sitting at the end of a table
and Bernstein and I were sitting
at the other end at a corner.
And we just carried on
with jokes and all kinds
of just interesting chit-chat.
And Harry said later, I
couldn't get a word in.
[laughter] And it was the first time
I'd come in to meet with Bernstein
after a long break and it was
like a friend, visiting him,
and it was what I had
seen for a couple years.
When I remember the
first time in Washington,
the first Bernstein friend to come
by was Roger Wilkins,
and it was exactly that.
He came in, he sat down, and
they hugged, and he sat down.
And Roger Wilkins had just
published his memoir at that point.
And I was just astonished at the,
you know, at this friendly banter
that Bernstein could have with
just about anybody under the sun.
And that was the first
time I actually had
that feeling for myself.
I thought, well, how sweet,
this could really be an
interesting guy to know.
But then, of course, I went
back into being the Assistant
for another year-and-a-half
and I should have quit.
>> Mark Horowitz: But he wrote
pieces of music for you and poems
and I mean he wouldn't do that
-- was that extraordinary, or?
>> Charlie Harmon: There were quite
a few people who got pieces of music
and poems, and they were
always very genuine.
And they took some
thought on his point.
However, the piece
of music with my name
in the title he didn't want
it published in the last group
of piano anniversaries
because he said the middle part
of the piece doesn't go anywhere.
[laughter] And I remember
saying, well, thanks a lot.
It's not random, but it's a
series of chords and it --
he's right, it doesn't
really go anywhere.
It has been recorded, actually.
I'm not sure that Boosie [Assumed
Spelling] has ever published the
printed music, but.
Yeah, so there's a
little bit of regret,
but at the same time
one very good friend --
I guess after Bernstein
died asked me if working
for him had changed my life?
And I said, not so much a
change, but the various aspects
of what I had always
found compelling --
music and language and
using the imagination,
being able to think
musically and think --
I mean the reason why I went to
Carnegie Mellon in Architecture was
because I've never had a problem --
it's so easy for me to imagine
interiors and exteriors and spaces
and volumes just in my head.
I think it's from having lived
overseas and visiting, you know,
a thousand different cathedrals and
castles and palaces and so forth.
And you just begin to think in this
way, and the history of architecture
and the history of
music and all that stuff
that I just I find so compelling.
And so with Bernstein it
was the first time all
of this could come together and
actually be useful and I could talk
to someone who spoke
to me as an adult
and who had interesting thoughts,
even though he really seemed
to know nothing about
the history of painting,
but he did understand certain
aspects of architecture.
And in terms of music, I mean I've
never spoken to anybody else who was
so articulate and who really
understood it from the inside, out.
So that was extraordinary,
but whether that was a change
in my life, I don't really think so.
It certainly made me into a
better, a more articulate person
and a better thinker, but I
don't think, I don't know,
I still haven't really
grown up so it's not,
that's not really a change.
[laughter] But it's a -- I wouldn't
say apotheosis, but it's a good sort
of summary feeling
that I got from him.
>> Mark Horowitz: A
good summary feeling,
I think that's an appropriate
time to end.
>> Charlie Harmon: And
it's all there in memoir.
>> Mark Horowitz: Soon
to be published by ...
>> Charlie Harmon:
Yes, Charlesbridge,
distributed by Random House, and
it should be out in March of 2018,
and the more I think about it
the more I would like it to be,
you know, like War and Peace,
it should just be enormous
but focusing will really help.
And the hardest thing, though, is
to get Bernstein to come to life
on the page, it's just
impossible, it's really impossible.
So it's my effort, anyway, it's
my contribution to the centenary.
>> Mark Horowitz: Thank you.
>> Charlie Harmon: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Mark.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.